independence is one of the central
concepts of probability theory because
it allows us to build large models from
simpler ones how should we define
independence in the continuous case our
guide comes from the discrete definition
by analogy with the discrete case we
will say that two jointly continuous
random variables are independent if the
joint PDF is equal to the product of the
marginal PDFs we can now compare with
the multiplication rule which is always
true as long as the density of Y is
positive so this is always true in the
case of independence this is true so in
the case of independence we must have
that this term is equal to that term at
least whenever this quantity the
marginal of Y is positive so to restate
it independence is equivalent to having
the conditional given Y be the same as
the unconditional PDF of X and this has
to be true whenever Y has a positive
density so that this quantity is
well-defined and it also has to be true
for all X's now what does this really
mean the conditional PDF as we have
discussed in terms of pictures is a
slice of the joint PDF therefore
independence is the same as requiring
that all of the slices of the joint have
the same shape and it is the shape of
the marginal PDF for a more intuitive
interpretation no matter what value of y
you observe the distribution of X does
not change in this sense why does not
convey any information about X notice
also that this definition is symmetric
as far as x and y are concerned so by
symmetry when we have independence it
also means that X does not convey any
information about Y and that the
conditional density of Y given X has to
be the same as
the unconditional density of Y we can
also define independence of multiple
random variables the definition is the
obvious one the joint PDF of all the
random variables involved must be equal
to the product of the marginal PDFs
intuitively what that means is that
knowing the values of some of the random
variables does not affect our beliefs
about the remaining random variables
finally let us note some consequences of
independent which are identical to the
corresponding properties that we had in
the discrete case and the proofs are
also exactly the same so the expectation
of the product of independent random
variables is the product of the
expectations the variance of the sum of
independent random variables is the sum
of the variances and functions of
independent random variables are also
independent which in particular implies
using the previous rule that the
expected value of a product of this kind
is going to be the product of these
expectations so independence of
continuous random variables is pretty
much the same as independence of
discrete random variables as far as
mathematics are concerned and the
intuitive content of the independence
assumption is the same as in the
discrete case one random variable does
not provide any information about the
other